- I'm not allowed to do takeout.
I'm not allowed to go out to a restaurant.
I am going to be making my food.
(upbeat music)
I am a bad cook.
I am a lazy person.
I don't have the time
and the patience to cook.
I really need to learn to cook a little
because, you know,
going out to restaurants
is wasting a lot of money.
My goal is to find one
meal that is easy to do
that I can do every week.
I realize I made a mistake
in that I froze the chicken
and it really needs to be defrosted.
So, we are going to have
some issues with that.
Timing things so that they end up
at the same time is difficult.
I'm really impressed with restaurants.
Pulled out the slow cooker
and um, just put all the
ingredients in there.
So tonight what I'm eating,
oh, it's so hot,
okay, that's the last
corn on the cob I had.
I bought that.
I didn't make it.
And that is the chicken
that was slow cooked
that I made up last night.
There's a feeling of accomplishment
when you finish cooking
a dish and it's edible.
But for me, it didn't happen that often.
I made some pretty bad meals.
I like fruit, but I heard
it's like healthy candy.
So, I'm trying not to get too much.
So right now I'm making a
peach and blueberry smoothie.
This isn't a recipe.
This is a made up recipe.
I don't know if the peaches
were the right decision.
I had an incident.
Okay, so I'm making a chicken
and broccoli casserole.
I left the plastic cover
on my casserole dish
and cooked it for about an hour.
I'm sorry, I'm just such an idiot.
I'm such an idiot.
Oh my god.
It's so embarrassing
because, you know, I feel
like 10 year olds know
you don't put plastic in the oven.
I know you don't put plastic in the oven,
but I put plastic in the oven.
The fumes from the burned plastic,
we were inhaling them and
we were poisoning ourselves
so we went outside.
It's not worth it.
Cooking's not worth it.
It really hurt my ego to learn that
I was that bad at cooking.
Right now I'm being very brave
and I'm making my pasta dish.
That's right.
I'm stepping it up.
I'm gonna eat healthy.
And also, I'm gonna eat food I cook
'cause that's gonna be a big step for me.
My goal is to find one
meal that is easy to do
that I can do every week.
♫ Pasta pasta Christmas pasta ♫
It's good.
I would eat it.
Just like I would eat every pasta.
(contented moaning)
I learned that I need very simple recipes.
I learned that I should follow recipes
because some people are born to cook
and others are not
and I am not.
Going buck wild and making things up
and that did not turn out well for me.